we will now hear from someone who is a
writer and who has a complicated
relationship with his language Adam
Gopnik who is an author and journalist
he has been a regular writer for The New
Yorker since 1986 and is the winner of
both the National Magazine Award for
essay in the George Polk award for
magazine reporting on a personal note I
just want to say that it always makes my
day sometimes makes my week of my month
depending on what other things look like
to open a new issue of The New Yorker
and see that it has an article bye-bye
Adam Gopnik articles like the delightful
when he wrote a few months ago about
snowflakes and how snowflakes are like
people because they become more
individual and more beautiful as they
fall to the ground before they melt that
was delicious the recent one that he
wrote on Get Smart that asks how will we
know when machines are more intelligent
than we are and that actually raises the
question of Google translators among
other among other things Adam has of
course a special connection to France
and perhaps he'll tell us a little more
this evening about how that connection
began he he spent five years living and
writing there for The New Yorker and his
essays were published in a book called
Paris to the moon he also published an
anthology called
Americans in Paris about Americans some
famous and some obscure who have lived
visited worked and written in Paris and
another of his books the king in the
window is a book of juvenile fiction
that's also set in Paris Adam is also
the author of angels and ages a short
book about Darwin Lincoln and modern
life through the Children's Gate and the
steps across the water and he has just
finished another France related book
called the table comes first on France
and the meaning of food to come out from
Knopf in October and we've already
invited him to come and talk about his
book here so come back for that in
October I turn it turn over to Adam
Gopnik
Thank You Jenny I can feel they stay
close to the mine I can feel the heat
rising in the room and I can see the
heat rising in your eyes so I will make
my remarks as short as I possibly can
it's very difficult to follow
three acts like that that display of
erudition and emotion and empirical fact
so I shall resort to to cheap nostalgia
in this is the second night in a row
speaking of my book on food that I have
been absent from the home kitchen and
from cooking and last night I was
speaking at the Metropolitan Museum
about seasons cardplayers I gave a gave
a lecture about Cezanne and then tonight
I explained to my hungry children that I
had to come up here and talk about why
French matters and my son turned to my
daughter and said daddy continues his
pathetic pursuit of a French decoration
now I mentioned that because not only
because it's true but also because it
had not occurred to me and this is the
point I wanted to make tonight it has
not occurred to me until he said that
that Cezanne was French
in that sense now of course I'm well
aware that's his honest French and when
I was speaking about him last night I
tried to talk about Susan's cardplayers
in the context of the creation of the
cafe the tavern the cult of tobacco in
the middle of the nineteenth century in
France and yet at the same time the
catalogue I was looking at was written
by Englishmen and Americans the context
in which Suzanne was being displayed was
the context of the great overarching
rainbow of Modern Art Suzanne is French
and at the same time in this very real
sense he's not French if there's one
thing it seems to me that the growth in
our understanding of humanism in the
past century has shown us is that
national boundaries the idea of Nations
is an ever mutable one and ever changing
one it's one that we declare as much as
one that we discover I was back up in my
hometown in Montreal
not long ago giving a talk and someone
at the end of the lecture said
accusingly why is it mr. Gopnik that in
your books and your writings about
French you always present yourself as an
American a naive who has just discovered
France when in fact you were brought up
and raised in an entirely francophone
environment which is true I come from
Quebec I come from the northern end of
the the Frank the francophone
Francophonie oh and yet necessarily in
order to articulate and express a
particular point of view I placed myself
in an American tradition national lines
national boundaries move all the time
and it's in that mutability exactly that
I think that they find their meaning um
I'm aware that the real question we have
to address tonight is not simply why
French matters because I could as my
predecessors have done so eloquently
explain to you why I love France as much
as I do
why French is some language worth
learning why French extends beyond the
narrow boundaries of France to be one of
the great international languages in
which new peoples find their voice and
find themselves quickly one of the
things I've written this year is a
profile in French for a French magazine
about Pierre Schneider the great art
historian the great biographer of
Matisse and one of the things that it
shocked me to discover is that Pierre
was born and raised in German in Germany
fled through France in 1940 on his way
to America and that was one year in
France was the totality of his knowledge
of France came to America for many years
and then went back to France and has
never surrendered his American
citizenship he's never gotten an
illusion as a matter of fact because he
won't become entirely French even though
he represents to the world until his
readers some of the gray some of the
great traditions of French Bell Etra and
I asked him why he didn't why feeling as
strongly as he did wanting to keep that
inherit that assumed American identity
he went back to France why did he go
back to France and he said exactly
because French was the only language in
which I could express myself it was a
choice of a language first before it was
a choice of a national identity that
kind of mute ability and that kind of
change is the kind of thing that I think
that we want to think about when we
think about when we think about these
questions let me say then that I think
that the real risk for Americans is not
simply the larger risk of insularity
which is the standard American disease
because I'm sure tonight in the casa
italiano and in deutsche house and in
many other places they're saying why are
we not teaching Italian why are we not
teaching German why are we not teaching
Russian and those are all legitimate
I'd say two things about that one is
that some to some degree the language we
arrive at as with Pierre has with Africa
as in Quebec to some degree is something
arbitrary about it that is we can't
decide what language we're going to
speak and yet the language we inherit
shapes the way that we articulate the
world but beyond that and this is why I
brought this anthology the interrelation
between France and America is one of the
richest and most complicated dialogues
that's ever taken place to shape the
consciousness of this country you cannot
write the history of American literature
without writing a history of the
experience of France
we can't understand Franklin James
Faulkner Fitzgerald Hemingway Edith
Wharton Elizabeth Bishop without
understanding their exposure to France
the rejection of France their embrace of
France and it would be the great sin of
amnesia to simply try and amputate or
end that particular dialogue or pretend
that it hasn't had the central and
shaping role that it has had let me add
one more thing one of the complaints
that's often made about those of us who
are a Francophile or passionately so or
even professionally so is that we the
France that we want to look at the
France that we celebrate the French
traditions that we love are masked or
partial in some way we talk about French
food and French dancing and French wine
and French pleasure and we deliberately
throw down a memory hole all of the
complicated torturous difficult and
painful history of France it seems to me
just the reverse is what we should be
emphasizing and articulate it's exactly
by looking frankly and boldly at the
difficulties the tragedies the pain and
the horror often of French history that
we exactly come into contact with both
the best and the worst sides of the
liberal humanist culture that we share I
did a piece about the Dreyfus Affair for
the magazine long essay about a year ago
and the point I wanted to make at the
same moment that our friends at the New
Republic were running a piece about how
the Dreyfus Affair showed the the
hopeless entangled
Frantz permanently in anti-semitism and
anti-semitic culture is that the amazing
thing about the Dreyfus Affair is that
for all its cruelty for all its bigotry
for all its its terrorists the system
the liberal Republican system worked
a man was wrongly accused by bigots
people acted on his behalf and
ultimately he was vindicated this was a
story that Americans at a time of
Guantanamo could take harden that is
that liberal Republican systems were
ultimately responsive even when they
were susceptible to the worst sides of
bigotry and cruelty I think the same
thing is true about the history about
the darkest hours in French life I think
it's true about Vichy I think that
Robert Paxton at this very University
has shown us again and again that the
not just the sin of forgetting but the
power of memory and few things in my
life have been more moving than being in
that courtroom in Bordeaux when when
Robert Paxton testified to great
references the only word I can think
about in the trial of Maurice Papon
those are the kinds of connections not
avoiding or evading the darker side of
French history but exactly confronting
it that makes this unnecessary and
ongoing dialogue it extends even I've
got to write an introduction to Hugo's
name Isikoff last year and the wonderful
thing about reading the Missal of this
account of the poverty oppression and
horror and cruelty of Paris in the mid
19th century is that so much of what
hugo dreamt up has come true a concert
of nations coalesced around liberal
values taking in all of europe with all
of its weaknesses with all of its
impotence that nonetheless was at the
heart a Victor Hugo's dream and the
story of how that came about through the
horrors of history is as well worth
telling as the story of why the Hugo
would have dreamt it in all of those
ways it seems to me that the darker side
of French history far from being
something that we Francophiles need to
repress is exactly what we need to
invite in for the education of America
and let me add only that though it's
certainly true that I would rather ride
in a metro
than in the subway I think we can all
agree that we would all rather ride in a
metro or a subway than a tube and let me
only add as well that if someone who
speaks only one language is an American
someone who speaks only one language
loudly is an American in Paris